واجهه ترامب معضله في العثور على محام
مؤهل من فلوريدا للانضمام الى فريق دفاعه
واشنطن بوست قالت ان محامين بارزين في
فلوريدا رفضوا الترافع عن ترامب بعد
استقاله اثنين من محاميه الرئيسيين
الاسبوع الماضي
اضافت الصحيفه ان ترامب امضى يوم الاثنين
في مقابلات مع محامين محتملين والاجتماع
بفريقه القانوني ومستشاريه لمناقشه القضيه
مستشار للترامب اشار الا ان التوت بلانش
سيقود فريق الدفاع كما فعل في قضيه ترامب
في نيويورك
خبراء قالوا لواشنطن بوست ان ترامب يعاني
في تعيين المحامين منذ انتخابه رئيسا عام
2016 بعدما عرف عنه تجنب المشوره
القانونيه احيانا وعدم الدفع لمحاميه في
احيان اخرى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات